Razzien in Kasernen in Wohnhäusern 137
Objekte in mehreren Bundesländern so die
Schlagzeilen heute eine Gruppe von
reichsbürgern sollen dem Putsch geplant
haben so der Generalbundesanwalt sie
wollten offenbar gewaltsam in den
Deutschen Bundestag eindringen
bundesinnenministerin Nancy Feser
spricht von einem Abgrund
terroristischer Bedrohung unter den
Festgenommenen Heinrich der 13 Prinz
Royce er sollte das neue Staatsoberhaupt
werden darüber sprechen wir jetzt hier
bei 8:15 Uhr stand Deutschland vor dem
Putsch also ich habe keinen Einblick in
die Ermittlungsakten ich kenne auch
keinen einzigen der Person die da jetzt
involviert sein sollen ich würde sagen
das hieße doch jetzt wirklich sagen
diese Fantasien über Gebühr ernst zu
nehmen wenn man sagen würde bestimmt
unmittelbar vor allem das kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen ich muss manchmal antun
Kuh denken ein österreichisches essen
damit gesagt Österreich ist eine
tödliche Operette und deshalb hat ja
beides hat was operettenhaftes also der
der alte Adlige der auch immer davon
geträumt hat quasi von Deutschland zu
werden also aber witziger geht's noch es
hätte ja nie im Leben geklappt das kann
man eigentlich nicht ernst nehmen diese
idiotischen absurden Vorstellung was man
allerdings ernst nehmen muss ist
natürlich wenn dort und das werden die
Ermittlung noch zeigen wirklich Waffen
gehortet worden sind wenn es
Schießübungen gegeben hat wenn es auch
Teil in der ehemaligen oder aktiven Teil
der der der
Bundeswehr gegeben hat dieses Jahr
beteiligt habe also Daten ehemalige
generell etc pp dann muss man diesen
Strang glaube ich schon sehr sehr ernst
nehmen aber das ist Leute gibt die sich
gerade im Internet oder in Kneipen
gegenseitig einreden mit ihnen gegen
alles besser die da oben können nichts
und mit den Räumen jetzt mal auf das ist
leider keine Neuigkeit das müssen wir
ernst nehmen aber nicht in Panik
verfallen also es sind keine harmlosen
Spinner kann man sagen sind beide sie
sind harmlose Spinner dabei einigen
Sicherheit und es sind einige dabei die
offenbar bereit gewesen wären es zum
Äußersten kommen zu lassen und wenn du
dort wirklich ist valide Überlegungen
gab von Erwägung war heute dreht aber
wenn es mal Lied Überlegungen Pläne gab
den Bundestag zu stürmen mit alt
Repräsentanten dieses Staates von der
Bildfläche verschwinden zu lassen etc
dann ist das selbstverständlich eine
ernsthafte Bedrohung unseres Rechtsstaat
und da muss der Rechtsstaat sich wehren
ob es deshalb jetzt nötig war 3000
Beamte einzusetzen und der Hälfte der
deutschen Presse vor Bescheid zu geben
damit auch schöne Fotos entstehen das
ist ein anderes Blatt
gerade angesprochen auch Kasernen wurden
untersuchte sorgt das ist auch für mich
die Gesprächsstoff bei der Bundeswehr
also ich habe da jetzt auch keinen
privaten Kontakt zu irgendwelchen
Verbindungen in dieser Richtung äh das
möchte ich direkt vorweg sagen ich habe
auch keinen Anruf heute bekommen dass
irgendwie
heilloses Durcheinander war aber ich
möchte vielleicht direkt auch sagen so
ein bisschen Vorsicht warten zu lassen
weil man ja immer gerne sagt die
Bundeswehr und die Soldaten und ich
finde das immer sehr sehr leidig wenn
man alle über einen Kamm schert und ein
paar
Außenseite gibt es immer aber ja bitte
nicht alle über einen Kamm scheren und
wir haben sehr sehr viele gute Jungs und
sehr viele Männer und Frauen die halt
wirklich das Land auch verteidigen und
eben für den Rechtsstaat auch einstehen
und das würde ich lieber unterstreichen
als dann zu sagen alle Soldaten sind
jetzt vielleicht wieder unter
Generalverdacht das ist ihnen natürlich
wichtig wir waren auch in ihr Thema
gleich noch tiefer einsteigen Herr Ernst
auch ihre parteivorsitzen hat gesagt
wenn ihr Wissler die Gefahr bewaffneter
Netzwerke muss man ernst nehmen das
würde dann mit dieser Aktion am heutigen
Tag muss man sagen auch getan ja Gott
sei Dank also bin ja dann Mitglied des
Bundestags bin ja anders betroffen und
deshalb denke ich schon dass wir genau
hingucken muss was da wirklich war
welche Verbindungen es gibt so Leute die
man noch nicht erwischt hat wollte nicht
die Spitze eines Eisbergs die jetzt
sichtbar wird ich bin voll oder Meinung
wir dürfen nicht alle Institutionen die
da sind und dann Generalverdacht stellen
aber wir müssen schon auch
sehen dass es dort in dem Bereichen auch
Netzwerke gibt immer aufklären muss und
aufdecken muss und deshalb ist auch
sinnvoll dass man entsprechende
Maßnahmen durch Studien macht
Untersuchungen anstellt von Seiten der
Behörden was du denn wirklich los ist
insbesondere dann wenn du auch Waffen
abgezweigt wurde und Munition abgezweigt
wurde und so also das ist ja wirklich
höchsten sie sich da als Politiker auch
bedroht wie schätzt persönlich nimmt ein
sehr ängstlicher Mensch aber ist
wenn man das Gefühl hat man konnte nicht
mal hingehen weil da sonst welche vor
der Tür stehen die die umnitten also da
muss man sagen besser vorher aus dem
Verkehr ziehen insofern wie viel Leute
man ist der einsetzen muss oder nicht
das kann eine beurteilen das müssen die
die machen die das dann machen machen
zum Beispiel meine Kollegin dailyn oder
auch Sarah Wagen nicht oder da ist dann
schon Deutschland auch schon Sicherheits
angesagt unterwegs ist habe ich gesagt
ich bin erstens kein sehr ängstlicher
Mensch und zweitens ist es so das bei
mir die Bedrohung auch ich nehme sie
nicht ernst
obwohl ich ernst heißt
in Deutschland hätten sowas überhaupt
für möglich nee natürlich hat man mal
von die reichburger vorher gehört aber
dass dann so Aktion jetzt auf einmal von
heute auf morgen
beschäftige
nicht jetzt probiert bezogen auf mich
meine Bilder aber ich nehme
in Deutschland das nehmen sie an aber
sie lassen sich jetzt in ihrem Alltag
als Politiker davon nicht verängstigen
und nicht beeinflussen verstanden
[Gelächter]